let's go hitze viel
in der geschichte zum
konversionsmaßnahmen in berlin um
religiöse gut wo glauben dass ihr
sexuelle neigung bian trainer-manager
ändere müssten mithilfe ganz oben jesus
sei die heimliche könig kind und jesus
sexuelles richtiger user teterow sind
krankheiten nur man kann heiler das
glauben zumindest seelsorgerin der beute
unter strom aus streng religiöser kreis
sie versprechend heilig für menschen im
clinch sind zwischen ihrem glauben ihren
gefühl das wird in der siebziger zeit
und selber eines padalino und könner
verdeckt aufzeichnen während alle
sitzigen angesprochen und da wird zum
beispiel die sexuelle neigung im gebet
losgesagt unter dem namen woher es
höchstens voller
die lösung von der geschlechter halle
geschleppt und aber von jesus christus
von 18 im namen jesu christi von az
[Musik]
ich wäre nie auf die deko zimmer bis 300
dass sie auf männer stehen umso mehr
können wir dir abstruse theorien und
schicksal wegnehmen stöhnt unter tut
[Musik]
das ist erstaunlich
wie manche fragten das so ist muss am
auto spielzentrale unserer vorstellung
die würde hätte das sexuelle empfinden
der morgenshow jährige von ihrem sollte
es wird
konsequenzen wenn man so siebziger
besucht wirklich anonym pole glaubt
wurde eine möglichst günstige
depressionen ängsten gas bezieht gedanke
für das
strengt sie es wagen muss eigentlich
wo dann ganz wurde angesetzt
[Musik]
zur muse finde was bis so heiler hinter
verschlossener tür passiert griffey zum
methode und nur in absoluten
ausnahmefällen zu haben die können ihre
skier mit falschem namen und filmer
verdeckt und das ist gutem grund zu
öffentlich interesse bietet thema ist
groß wie ist ihre meinung
als journalist hätte wohl mir ein termin
gelegt denn die leute sind sich bewusst
dass so konversionsmaßnahmen
gesellschaftlich umstrittene sind ab
jetzt heißen über witz
perfektes wetter für das was mein handy
unterwegs zur ersttherapie session und
die eine zu starke gegner danach
überlegen wir bis maximal 19 grad
irgendwer weiß auch nicht also gibt's
der
kamera übernehmen ihre kollegin an
erfüllt fahrt und 70 die abneigung der
plan ist eigentlich folgende netz mit
verschiedener seelsorger und beraterin e
mail kontakt kam
und da gefragt ob man dauernd die macher
mit der homosexualität von guido dass
ich mein auto ego
streng religiös aber halt auch
realisiert weiße stoffbänder kann man
das nicht irgendwie
weg therapie und jetzt können wir zu
einer forelle von einem untermieter
botter 1 3
unterwegs ich will mir versteckt mit -
smartphone
[Musik]
jetzt sie wolle willen - zürich
noch über ihre stunden dich das ganze
city
lights go
viel
mit analogie schon mal was sie dort
verstörendes erlebt haben
was rechtliche gründe ruhm unkenntlich
gemacht und stimmt für fremdes spiel
nicht gelernt und später ausbricht
individual psychologische beraterin aber
nicht studiert psychologie gehen aber ja
so ein psychologisches politik gemacht
und zwar am institut für richters und
eheberatung
das thema gewinnt
hanni aufstocker ja ja sie haben im
internet hat lässt auch schon
möglichkeiten gibt so
dass der pc in sehr sehr guter
ja
also wir wissen du ganz konkret gewusst
dies problem beschrieben ich glaube das
problem ist dass sie
mind
ja das ist für probleme ja ich bin's
also mega mutig dass dies ist wollte
herr
stunde des kindes kann in der arbeit ja
es ist egal wie kurz ist meint sie
wollte seine identität absprache
dass gott nicht nein das geht überhaupt
nicht
es ist ja nicht so dass sexualität die
ganze identität ist aber sich daher
davor wo einfach ich und nöte mit
sturheit ob du fragt ob das kind
missbraucht wurde wahrscheinlich soll
eine dürfen sind und das sind los
das kann viele kinder
wie sie versuchen sich unbewusst ab mai
gibt es andere schlacht entwickler hast
du
denn schwere traumatische erlebnis
bin relativ dunkel co
ja wie sieht das denn strikt tätigen
deshalb staustufen du
als kind
ich habe natürlich alle sie die
entsprechende meine kindheit ist super
so das argument wo hat die christliche
theorie entkräftigt die therapeutin zeit
will der wieder für andere jungs knapp
war das egal wer sie genau wie die jungs
sind die mir vorstelle gaal und das ist
jetzt nur eine zahl von dem was ich
jetzt härter wenn wir es die das noch in
mähren mit sprach noch genau wo ich die
mir forscher dass der kleine diego wird
es sehnsucht entwickelt hat und
unbewusst ist eine lüge
entstanden nur wenn ich auto zur kur zu
den jungs glaubte kleine
guido dass ich auch bin und da bin ich
habe den wagen saß d'amour studie
schaffen
dura stadt geschaffen dass
das braucht aber du bist jung und das
ist einfach irre die malta als wir mit
80 aber ich war bereit mit dir dein werk
und zwar mit jesus team innere kind
begangen
die idee für diese stunde ausgebaut und
vielleicht können bildet aber wir sind
trotzdem im dialog und das kostet das
wie wie funktioniert das so normal wie
frau stützen das gespräch 100 frank wenn
das finanziell nicht drin liegt hast du
mir auch dann wenig
ich wäre froh wenn du mir das bad
und sonstwie advent oder genau via
italien
ja
dass das heil barisch acht bis zehn
siebziger 100 starts drei wochen
bin schon ganz aufgeregt sind sie schon
mega light wo das glauben jetzt freut
man sich automatisch mein gott welt mehr
mache dass ich es so klar ist ich muss
ihnen hält wenn es geeignet so logisch
dass du mit ja aber passt für mich
gemacht
was ich glaube ich wenn du als 15 16 17
jähriger das realisiert und im einer das
ist auch wieviel nachmittag so wenn du
irgendwo als einzigen im dorf wachsen
quasi wie nie denn hätte mit 15 wenn man
das der amerika kommt es doch einmal und
ich hoffe wirklich dass das irgendwie er
umgelegt wurde das recherchieren und das
wirklich ein macher
das video das homosexualität krankheit
ist wissenschaftlicher konsens studie
aus kanada sei dabei dass trotzdem grund
sei vor allem der lgbt kyu menschen
irgendwann mal in kontakt mit zur
kompostierung maßnahme chor singend in
der schweiz wird die zahl enders sie
was
interessant ist die dem
sport mit der
therapeutin seelsorgerin hat seinen
namen erwähnt nämlich alfred adler und
täschchen regen wir an dir mal gut letzt
das ist ein psychologe vor 150 hofft
welt ist und der theorie und welt
gestellt ist im buch das heißt das
problem der homosexualität dass der
sieg kommt durch komplex oder durch
traumatische erlebnisse die kindheit
jetzt an aber normalen termin das motiv
zum glück der mossad ruby und sie
schiebt sogar auf ihrer website dass sie
noch alfred adler quasi praktiziert bin
gespannt was sie seit denkmodell so der
individualpsychologie ist folgendes
homosexualität ist konsequenz wo es ein
schlechter kindheitserlebnis entstanden
ist und auch rückgängig gemacht werden
kann die eto riesch total veraltet wird
aber trotzdem unter vetrag wendet
soligie domini next erbeuten verspricht
mehr heilig auf jede fahrt von mensch zu
mensch anders grüße menschen können die
schlussendlich heterosexuelle anderen
edgar
degas mitspracherecht
der mit sage ich sage ja du wirst auf
jeden fall und tranche vorfall ohne
probleme sexualität wachsen das kann ich
dir tatsächlich nicht so sagen auch
darauf verzeihlich verbundene komplex
und sie meint wir müssen die das ufh
arbeiter und nach erwarte mit dem see
was das für auswirkungen auf die neigung
ist das gut
als brutal anstrengend umso höher das
ist eine art wirklich
anscheinend oft mit viel konflikte der
kindheit store hat das ganze system
jetzt mega blöd und gäste bin ich froh
sie hat nicht an amerika ihr werdet so
voll war
schon wirklich scheiße ist das wirklich
so
ist so spur hinterlasse spuren tja ich
meine machen zumal aber andere lied
machen jahre langsam steuert und mit
seinem inneren
kompressionstherapie thal gäu und
werden karten ist und wenn gerade du sag
ich das ja fragen wir ihn doch am besten
in unser wachstum es in einer freikirche
luft wachsen
übler startklar norma und frauke themas
homosexualität das tabu wo er sich
gemerkt hätte dass die wähler weg um ihr
der breeze
[Musik]
um 23 uhr kompressionstherapie finden im
freikirche das setting stadt lud der
studie aus kanada
der duster hängt der grund wieso
überhaupt mit der reportage angefangen
hat
will donnerstag ist dann irgendwie die
story xaver käser hat hey das ist cool
aber wenn der schweizer paar sachen oder
lediger oder problem wo man noch and und
ja dass das ganze thema konversions
therapien erlaubt ist ja dass ich also
dein problem
wie fing es problematisch wenn es
wirklich so aus kommissionspapier
aufträgt und je nachdem junge liegt dazu
verpflichtet weiter das zu machen
brandneu tickt weiter dass sie das
machen das findet definitiv nicht gut
also ja viele therapeuten und so
geschrieben und bin
und es ist so
also eine zigarette bedarf wie du hast
es ja
jahrelang gemacht ja ja ja fast zehn
jahre und ich bin schon auch eine halb
stunde
sie ihr dank eines
bedürfnisses sie ich habe aber nochmals
weiter ja und du ja wahrscheinlich nicht
und genau das macht uns und für mich
wird dieser traum kann ich das wirklich
woanders vater und mein team muss anders
war hat er glaube nicht dass ich beides
kriegen wir am vatertag sich was sie
erlebt hat
bislang immer mehr andere hört seine
songs etwa der andere bin dankbar
aber denn
habe sich mit luckhaus
negative aufgelegt das vom islam sc
oxidative andere kundschaft und das
thema und du merkst du
überlegst du keinen sinn vor es geht
vorwärts
dadurch entstand sie mitmachen das ist
für mich verstehen sie und logisch
sehr viel angst und panik oscars
depressionen muss klar ist wo womit der
stationäre therapie habe hunger ist
ja
ich
muss ehrlich sagen okay ich bin ich
heute dankbar dafür wo es mir zudem
macht
überzeugt die wahrheit also das ist so
ich
hab das nicht gemacht und da
waren die extrem cool und bin ich selbst
geräte mit dem bin ich dankbar
aber
wünsche ich niemandem nehmen
definitiv nicht
nach zehn jahren mehrere therapeuten und
es zerstört selbstwertgefühl hat er eben
ventfair signalkette wo sie nie rettig
sich gott hat mich seit heimat
die so scharf wie du bist mit der
homosexualität und das ist gut so das
darfst du sie oder darf das aber darf
nicht nur sie sondern du darfst du soll
aber
und so viel gewicht von mir ab
gebe aber definitiv die manic das ist
sehr schade wenn sie die einzige die
einzig wagen nur durch die therapie und
merken das macht kein fortschritt und du
im arbeitskreis liegt am meer und seine
gut und ihr wort zu wenige und die geber
zu wenig denn ist definitiv
lachen
und
darum haben uns nicht auf die leichte
schulter
in der schweiz ist das ganze nicht
wirklich erforscht deutschland hat
studien und passieren die studie hat
deutschland das ja von butter und
also dass modezar schmidt auf die
leichte schulter du kannst nicht mit
wohin zieht triebe werden weil die so im
clinch sind
mit sich und der homosexualität und ok
und vielleicht daran dass
suizidalität oder angesprochen heißt es
dass
ein
stressiges wagens eigentlich
wo das ganze würde es an die sätze
zum glück nummer vorstellung blieb aber
es gibt ja verschiedene organisationen
wo es ist verbot fordert
vor so therapie
und
auch schon im nationalrat mit der
emotion und der boden ist heute seiten
grundsätzlich im rat für die konversion
stamp er aber ihr wort stadt bis zu
bitter es ist macht ihn jemand werbe
damit verdeckt arme zum könner
koordiniere richtig
also
ich sehe nicht wie man das wie man das
kontrolliert wir haben ihr von der
konversions therapie ableitet
das ist einfach therapie xiii
umgang mit sexualität
und das wird auch in zukunft
gar leide ja
ja der punkt in der schweiz in so verbot
für konversionsmaßnahmen nun weniger
kanton in arbeit auf nationaler ebene
statt letzteren versuchen zwei neue
parlamentarische initiative sind aber
bereits in anderen ländern ist das
verbot schon realität gerade anfang 20
22 et canada zum beispiel
kompressionstherapie roboter
es ist süd-chemie letzte mini kollegin
anna dabei aber nur auf der fahrt einen
termin wieder halt seine frau den termin
aber noch damit problematik von guido
geschildert haben will homosexualität
laut sich anscheinend nicht nur durch
therapie sondern bei ihnen durch gebet
heiler das binäre organisation wo sehr
viele millionen franken an spender und
stickt jedes jahr
gott mehr
passieren
so mikrofon versteckt damit man der
tonga luft
sendegebiets um filme und so mancher was
jedoch keine fehler mehr weiß es nicht
das gefühl die sind shops medien
erfahren konnt mallorca was hast du es
rät ihr vorschlag sehen dass in so einer
stunde das 1
und das sind die letzten bilder von ihr
könne mache dass sie mehrere lied wurde
heilsarmee maxi dabei haben - smartphone
aber wie sehr berater mikrofon trotzdem
muss zeichnet unter seelsorge
auszuweisen angespannt fragen
außer guido jetzt erstmal ganz wichtig
herr jesus und mehr reguliert so wie du
bist aber
jetzt die homepages der metris quartetts
schlafenden hatte modelliert würde das
nicht cool finde aber mehr hatte die
genau gleich wird unter der jesus hat
jesus christus mit priester des dgh
reine show wir finden das toll und ich
danke dir dass du die lose kritisch das
erhöht für deinen empfindet wohin
zerstört unter dem namen jesus christus
von nazareth
vor der
gefühle zueinander für direct so gekühlt
sieht man dass sie mich vor ort so
geführt dass sie mit zum anlass um die
lieder vor
im namen jesus
jesus von nazareth im namen christi
formen an
nach eineinhalb stunden ist das ganze
für big sie dem ruf sie mit zwei junge
seelsorger plus drei bis vier rück oder
die ganze zeit am bett
glaubt und natürlich der seelsorge von
der heilsarmee da eine wiederum wahre
geschichte erzählt über den vater war
auf die bislang sich aber wenn es jetzt
so hätte das alles nicht mit
zurück im büro mit anders sind gedanken
von uns beiden viele klagen langsam
keine ordnen was mehrere seelsorger von
heyl zum x1
während mir erzählt was die mega kassen
ein dass er ganz viele lucio
golf erhält er hat ganz viele
homosexuelle phänomene und trans
menschen wo
noch dem 7 sie sind wirklich ein können
zeigen ich bin das gar nicht ich bin
hetero und noch einmal einer
viertelstunde der größte an was es liegt
nämlich an einem weniger schlechten bzw
zum beispiel das segelboot bei mir und
bei vielen anderen seite bisher neben
der tonaufnahme regal haben das seit ich
zum beispiel es ist sehr oft so in
homosexualität
gleichgeschlechtlicher also wenn man
sich gleichgeschlechtliche gefühlt sehr
oft
dass die kapazitäten vater harry potter
sexuelle missbrauch okay bei dir ist
nicht messbar aber dass ich keine
beziehung zum vater des 14 oft aber
ähnlich schlecht lichkeit das ist
absolute kuchen psychologie aber leider
werden genauso jährige immer wieder bot
der seit religionswissenschaftler
adriano motiv
im zahlt ihm eine reportage
[Musik]
die adresse von jobsuchern seien keine
einzelfälle
es ist verbreitet die der schweiz zahler
kamen aber nicht erheben alles passierte
steckt sieht jahre vorstellt zu dem
thema und für die forschung mit vielen
alytus freikirchliche kreis geredet
sogar genau mit dem boni absurd an und
das du nie anders als im inneren
reportage moderne hat das hat mir
gegenüber gross tritt ab jetzt
interessante gesetzt auch im doppel ist
kurs über gewusst hat dass die forschung
betrieben nicht inkognito gesehen hätte
sagt wesentlich vorsichtiger und
rücktour mega kompetenzen im interview
die mit homosexuellen
ökonomie selber schaffen sondern die
immer wieder bewiesene seelsorger und
entsprechend die sbg und eigentlich
sofort eine gewährt ab oder surft man
mache ich jetzt natürlich ganz angst und
das ist ja auch der grund wieso das
andere körper gemacht er will sich ja so
sowie material mit höheren hebel wenn
die mit der kamera quasi offene welt
ganz genau aber wieso wenn die so
überzeugt sind wieso sind in dir so
schreckhaft segement die novartis
diskurs geht form vom erwachen die
gesellschaft wie es da läuft die themen
es jedoch langsam mit der öffentlichkeit
und sie nahm er sich selbstständig war
öffentliche debatte aus im internet der
religiöse minderheit wo sie hofft dass
auch wie die haut vom markt juli
turnusgemäß die
gierig probiert immer mehr die
initiative herz beschnitten und sie
funktioniert auf der straße hinterher
war nahm ich und was man natürlich
musste ist das starker
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse vor der figur
der bewegung auch sie haben mit pastor
den pastor ad networks ltd sei aber in
der ganzen frage von homosexualität bin
ich selber wieder erkennbar dass
eigentlich dringend muss die geschichte
theologie und das anerkennen weder von
spenden finanziert verlegt wurde es
anders gesehen und so taucht sie als
pastor würde
mini theologische haug hat sich geändert
würde ihm aufblüht der vorläufe sie
kommen wie gefährlich das ist schon
existenzielle bedrohung vor ihnen und
das endet fortschritte denn am ende ganz
ganz stark und schärfer die gründe um
das theologische schwitzen ohne tut und
das ist natürlich überall bestehen über
die stehen mit mit möglichen
wissenschaftlicher perspektive so die
beraterin hat chris university
psychologie studium gibt also dass sie
nicht lügt wo ein arnika es dann
gewitter dann sehen die er ihr kurz
besucht oder ist die frau retten idealen
ausbildung macht alles stark überformt
vor dem evangelikaler welt und
menschenbild und
der umstand dass nicht das ist ein
konstrukt geht wohl jeder logik aber wo
natürlich eine universität die
wissenschaftliche perspektive
psychologie das ist
und genau wie kleine wunder bis zu
machen die das jetzt sehen wir ja wieder
einer ludwig sie verdeckt und deshalb
ist nur fair wenn man ihn jetzt als
chance kennt zum
standpunkt verteidigen eigenhändig
geschrieben per mail und besetzen nur
woher meine arbeit gehört deshalb eine
denkt liegt kommentar und lockt was das
sehr
kurzum sie will die zeiger anbieter
lust zum fc
valencia berufsrichter dass sie nicht
fechterinnen vor der therapie segen und
religion etablierten
auf unterhaltsame einmal gehört und zwar
via e-mail derzeit unter anderem die
heilsarmee bietet keine
kompressionstherapie sie lehnt diese ab
hätte sich der reporter als
homosexueller geoutet und den wunsch
geäußert diese ausleben zu wollen wäre
unser seelsorgeteam anders vorgegangen
als im film dargestellt aber
trotzdem sie hält homosexualität vom
grieder unseriös weg erklärt und sogar
wetter soll bis löst die hilfe suchen
die kein konflikt sondern macht sie nur
noch schlimmer wir mirbeth gesehen ich
muss für mich das rechte bewegende
geschichte das ganze wir haben relativ
viel mit dem musiker gesetzt was so
konversionsmaßnahmen auslösen könnte wir
küssen menschen und der hat es ganze
leben zerstört aber was sie aussehen ich
glaube an die seelsorge therapeuten
pastore glaubte man das nicht aus ihrer
böswilligkeit sondern glaubte meinen es
gut die ins kühle sieht denn das
misereor
helfer user rechte sogar und checken
cnet dass sie alles nur noch schlimmer
machen ich finde das kann man schon im
hinterkopf behalten aber es ist absolut
keine entschuldigung vor allem mit mütze
dax was ich stehe nicht auf das ganze
thema konversionsmaßnahmen schrieb
kommentar und nächste woche in den
kindergarten auf eure fragen nicht
welcher job ist und auch noch gratis
abonnieren
[Musik]